wie eine frau sich trotz ihres
andersseins einen festen platz in der
gesellschaft erkämpft hat davon erzählt
dieser film olga user 81 jahre alt wird
den im gasthof rössle in näfels ist
kleinwüchsig in ihrer kindheit und
jugend wurde sie oft gehänselt aber sie
ließ sich nicht unterkriegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jedes fröhlich auch an der see
unterlagen also hast nicht wieder machen
da wird schon wohnt in die kälte und
daran halte ich mich darum gestellt zu
machen fröhlich sehen
das ist einfach so schön das wetter aber
völlig fasziniert vom unbekümmerten
herzlichkeit den irgendwer gesteckter
samir auswählen ich finde das
fantastisch dass die person woher
eigentlich mitglieder größe praktisch
und tanzenden ich schon zufrieden
das spiel also grad immer gestartet
[Musik]
doch verdorben daumens klar
dabei
[Musik]
der ganze baum
für die katholiken ist näfels mit seiner
barocken kirche und dem kloster maria
burg so etwas wie der hauptort ihres
glaubens im kanton glarus der ansonsten
mehrheitlich reformiert ist in der nähe
des klosters im historischen dorf teil
steht das restaurant rössli wo olga seit
über 60 jahren wird
[Musik]
olga kommt am 17 juli 1937 zur welt sie
ist das erste kind des ehepaars user
nach olga bekommt das paar noch sechs
buben
es ist nicht sofort klar dass olga
kleinwüchsig ist ausbilder hat normal
sei dass babys die kranken wichtig sid
gemein
vielleicht hat sie sich als stifter
selbst kyoto die 20 folgen erlernen das
heute wohl als er berührt aber einmal
gesehen
es ist vielleicht merkt dass ich das mit
mir auf syrien kinderspital und täter
hat der muss das tun was ich liebe
[Musik]
es handelt sich um auch controller sie
die häufigste form des genetisch
bedingten kleinwuchs
ach und brasilien steht häufiger durch
neue mutationen als durch vererbung auch
in olgas familie ist bislang kein fall
von kleinwuchs bekannt bis 20
es sei wichtig dass du den stehen die
brille und und und
[Musik]
es geht nach rapperswil vollgas
großeltern gelebt haben wo sie als kind
oft die ferien verbracht hat und wo die
boutique ist bei der sie ihre kleider
kauft
[Musik]
das mobil
auch schneider was will ich gerade mal
sowie kaum auf das anbieten
kleider ab stange kaufen und anziehen
das kann euch gar nicht wie bei 83 sie
typisch sind ihre beine und arme im
vergleich zum normal großen oberkörper
stark verkürzt die kleider müssen
deshalb stets abgeändert werden
schulz billig kostbar und olga land im
rössli bei der mutter das wirken macht
später auch dass wirte patent die mutter
kann die hilfe gut gebrauchen denn der
vater ist an multipler sklerose erkrankt
[Musik]
ja
im rössli gibt es keine so genannte
behindertengerechten baulichen
anpassungen nichts ist extra für olga
umgebaut
eine sonderbehandlung erfährt sie von
klein auf wird ihr eingetrichtert sie
müsse lernen sich in der welt der groß
gewachsenen zu behaupten
[Musik]
die audio politischen gremien
kollektoren stoff beherrscht
kinoliebhaber schwarz werden oder es
[Gelächter]
nicht allein
[Musik]
das sind
im rössli verliebt sich olga in einem
zimmer gast sie ist 18 32 sie wird
schwanger
nicht ungefährlich für die kleinwüchsige
frau
[Musik]
die mutter bringt olga nach zürich ins
universitätsspital
doppel sechs mit und ochse ernst ist ein
ständig unterwegs ist muss man sich das
vorstellen
mit dem beschluss
und da hab ich gesagt dass ich das nicht
gesagt
es klingt auch so und warum wollen sie
als durch sein
und da besser hat man fast buchstäblich
danach halten grüne ins boot zu haben
wollte und zum 22
olga sohn walter ist mittlerweile 62 und
lebt bis heute bei seiner mutter
er versteht dass sie das recht ihn nicht
einfach so aufgeben wollte ohne vater
aufgewachsen macht sich als junger mann
dann doch einmal auf die suche nach dem
unbekannten vater
so steigere lehren daraus zu ziehen
also dort wo man auch mal wehtun
und dann wurde ich einfach da passt
[Musik]
natürlich gibt es als olga mutter wird
gerade im dorf eine frau die ledig ein
kind bekommt und dazu noch eine
kleinwüchsige
[Musik]
grüße ich die schönsten braucht
heute sorgen nicht mehr die
vermeintlichen sünden der mitmenschen
für gesprächsstoff in näfels
sondern der unablässige verkehr mitten
durch das dorf überall user von ihren
freunden ribéry oder all genannt
tuschelt niemand mehr hinter ihrem
rücken
man begegnet ihr mit respekt
[Musik]
wie die meisten menschen mit ach und
trockner sie leidet sie an
rückenproblemen
sie muss den betrieb im restlichen 20
und da hat der dhb hat ja was machen mit
durchhalten
und jetzt das
das blättern im fotoalbum
einmal im jahr macht olga ferien vom
wrestler und bereits mit ihrer mutter
die welt
in zeiten in denen auslandsreisen noch
außergewöhnlich sind für frauen sowieso
gestorben
das sollte und das
[Musik]
das glarnerland feiert es ist fahrt der
gedenktag an die gewonnene schlacht bei
näfels alu 1388 gegen die österreicher
dann zieht jeweils die gesamte glarner
regierung in einer prozession von clarus
nach näfels
für wird in olga ist die fahrt der
wichtigste tag im jahr
denn direkt vor dem rössle auf dem
fahrplatz macht die prozession halt
[Musik]
olga bietet für diesen tag mehrere
helferinnen und helfer für service und
küche auf am vatertag herrscht im rössli
hochbetrieb wie in früheren zeiten an
jedem wochenende
[Musik]
der unter dem jahr geschlossene saal ist
an diesem tag zum leben erweckt
olga user hätte an ihrem schicksal
zerbrechen können sie ist es nicht
vielleicht weil sie beschlossen hat mit
frohsinn gegen die traurigkeit
anzukämpfen
[Musik]